in the last episode of season's
greetings I visited the north of Finland
where a flesh and blood center trade me
for a tough job then in Berlin I found
the perfect outfit waiting for st. Nick
nowhere else does that mean what it does
at the Santa winter games the whole town
of Gary vara has turned out the games
have taken place here in northern Sweden
11 times now it's the event of the year
back at the hotel contestants like Santa
ho ho Holland are warming up he's
participated five times and won twice
his costume projects power this guy goes
for the sumo look australian-born Santa
Glenn is taking part for the first time
even though he's been playing the role
down under for over 20 years he gives me
a few tips merry christmas merry
christmas and a happy new year then
we're off it's my first real public
appearance as Santa makes me feel a
little shy among all of these
experienced colleagues number 20
not only do a medium french mrs. Santa
Claus there are also even contestants
here from mainland China and Hong Kong
all of them have to apply back in July
to take part in the Santa winter games
and they're all ready to fight for the
title the first discipline is the
reindeer rodeo after real animals cost a
few injuries in the past contests
mechanical bull now does the honors the
Santa who stays in the set along ghus
twins by the time my turn rolls around
the leader has managed 39 seconds I've
never done anything like this before in
the end I managed 13 not bad actually
for a first goal in a challenging
category ray said go the next discipline
is the porridge eating contest
apparently this disgusting dish is
Santa's favorite food I don't get it by
the time I've managed to choke down my
first spoonful of the lukewarm paste
Center yamashita from Japan and center
sunny from Hong Kong have already
finished I can't believe it they must
have slept it down without chewing I end
up in second to last place
and then it straight to the next task
each Santa has two minutes to build the
highest tower he can out of a pile of
presents you have a tip for me what
should I do the big present first
there's a brilliant idea thank you very
much then it's my turn if I don't make
up some lost ground here I'll be in
serious trouble this is my last chance
if I blow it I'll be out of the running
for the title and how hard can is being
right but even though I'm the tallest
Santa here I still only manage second I
just have to accept it someone else will
carry home the laurels at this winter
games next up the center triathlon will
help you with this keys can someone help
me I never did this before way too many
firsts in a single day for my taste
shortly before the starting gun I try to
get a feel for the skis I'm off to a
brilliant start first out of the blocks
haruki in the Santa winter games is in
the lead and these until shortly before
we switch to space I'm not going to let
one little tumble stop me next I go with
a slave full of presents all of them
have to remain on board my final round
is on a traditional Finnish push sleigh
in the end I cross the line behind most
of the other competitors but at least
they're nice about it oh thank you like
all of the other centers from Asia
center sunny is very ambitious one
reason why is that he's been sponsored
by mall in Hong Kong back home he even a
twin a qualification round to be
selected to go to the games in Sweden
but at the end of the day he's edged out
by Santa yamashita from Japan
the success says the champion is not his
alone he was trained by Santa Yamamoto a
veteran of the Santa winter games after
the heat of the battle the day ends on a
warm and friendly note I have to say
that I never would have thought the
competitors take the game so seriously
to be fair the disciplines didn't really
play to my personal strengths but still
I now slowly but surely feel like I'm
growing into the role I've chosen to
play this Christmas
on the next episode of season's
greetings I head back to Berlin where
her family is in need of my Santa
services I also visit a Christmas market
and a company's you tight office party